here are the faces of lillian gish
miss Lillian
as DW Griffith used to call her is the
youngest human being in the theatre
tonight
if youth be measured by zest enthusiasm
and sheer physical strength this
beautiful woman so frail and pink and so
overwhelmingly feminine has endured as a
working artist from the birth of the
movies to their Transfiguration for
underneath this wisp of a creature there
is hard steel in the hundreds of films
she is made she and her beloved sister
Dorothy coped with danger and peril
beyond mortal measures that beleaguered
girl is a solidly professional actress
and I should know because I had the good
fortune to direct her some years back
and show no cases play within the gates
I found her to be what we call a pro and
there's no greater acolyte oh yes one
one greater for an actress to be loved
and admired by her leading men and she
ran the gamut from Richard ii to Richard
the first miss Lillian has written a
book about all this sternly called the
movies mr. Griffith and me note the
order in her dedication she wrote to my
mother who gave me love to my sister who
taught me to live to my father who gave
me insecurity to DW Griffith who taught
me it was more fun to work than to play
high time we dedicated something to her
and so to lillian gish who has touched
all of our lives with her gifts her
dignity her funny little smile and her
immense invulnerability the members of
the Academy and millions of millions of
people in the audience say you have
taught and keep teaching us that time is
an ally that laughter in tears coexist
that you're starring light is luminous
and gentle yet pierces the darkness come
and get your long-overdue Oscar miss
Gish miss lillian gish miss Lillian
I'm speechless and there are only two
words that I can say for my beloved
sister and myself for this warm tribute
from all my friends and all of you of
the Academy thank you and oh the
charming ghosts I feel around me who
should share this it was our privilege
for a little while to serve that
beautiful thing the film and we never
doubted for a moment that it was the
most powerful thing the mind and
heartbeat of our technical century I
hope we served it well and I do thank
you
with all my heart for all of us that
this represents